and you know what time it is it's
mondays with monica
monaco jackson talking about some back
to school things right
oh absolutely bianca by the way you're
holding it down here
i'm trying girlfriend you know you set
the bar high i'm trying to
i'm just trying to reach i'm trying to
get in the region in the region
you're there you're there my friend
looking good sounding good
all right and bianca you're right it's
all about back to school again i
remember as a kid i hated hearing that
and we're still on summer vacation but
you know as a parent now we got to get
it together ccsd students are returning
to class a week from today so
the kiddos and their parents we're all
going to be out doing that back to
school shopping the dreaded
back-to-school shopping parents i know i
hate it anyway
some of them probably are going to be
over at galleria at sunset and joining
me this morning
is the lady in charge of the mall so
don't cut up because you're going to
have to deal with her if you do
her name is andrea blue and she's going
to fill us in on the covet protocols for
your shopping and you know everything
you need to know as you and the kiddos
get out there
andrea thank you so much for joining us
how you doing this morning
i'm doing well monica thank you for
having me absolutely okay first of all
let's clear something up
i got um it was a previous marketing uh
team there at galleria mall
i would always say galleria mall you
don't say galleria mall
it's galleria at sunset because you tell
everybody
it's sunset yeah it's gallery at sunset
because galleria means mall
so if you're saying gallery and mall
you're saying mall mall
exactly and gallery of sunset is the
name of the mall is the name of the mall
all right hey let's write let's get
right into it though uh andrea
uh the malls reopen right and
with that sentiment uh your average
shopper they're going in there but a lot
of us are going in with a lot of
trepidation
what is the sentiment of your average
shopper that you've noticed
since everything is reopening
everybody's kind of easing back into it
and the mass mandates are back
well with the uptick in traffic monika
it's evident that shoppers are ready to
get out the house
and as your community shopping center
this is the place where friends come
to enjoy some time away from home and
while we are
while we provide a clean safe cool
shopping environment because it is hot
outside being able to touch your clothes
try them on
switch sizes is an experience you can't
replicate online
okay i love that because that was going
to be one of my questions can people try
clothes on what's that been like so
thank you
for answering that what about the
retailer speaking of the clothes
have you been able to retain you know
those staple stores andrea
and have you been able to attract other
retailers because some have left
well you know gallery at sunset has been
opening and closing stores
for over 25 years yeah we are expert at
taking spaces wiping them clean and
reinventing them to make room for a
new uses and experiences we're always
looking for ways to bring
something new to life and that no one
has seen before and deliver to this
community
i love it so what type of incentives are
you offering to customers
over at sunset to bring them in
yesterday i'll tell you i did my
homework
i took a quick uh like a site survey and
i saw there were a couple stages
that were decorated i saw some beautiful
balloons i saw some nice backgrounds
there what are you guys doing
well in partnership with henderson
police henderson fire and anthem's blue
cross
we had a successful back to school
public safety expo last thursday
where we gave away 700 backpacks filled
with back-to-school supplies
nice so what we would like to yes it was
very successful and the turnout was
wonderful
i would like to extend that offer to the
henderson families
who did not get a chance to come out
last thursday to come to the management
office to grab a backpack
filled with school supplies to help kick
off their back-to-school shopping
we have around a hundred pack backpacks
they're gonna go fast
so make sure that you come out to the
management office that's awesome
you're giving free you've got about 100
left so mom and dad if you haven't
gotten the backpacks full of school
supplies
andrea just said they have about a
hundred left at the galleria manager's
office so get there today okay go ahead
i love this giveaway
that's great our retailers are also
offering back-to-school specials
so check out our website gallery at
sunset.com to see all of our
participating tenants
this is i had no idea she was going to
do that folks i'm so excited right now
okay so what advice would you give
parents uh andrea if they're coming out
now
the kids are fatigued you know so you
got to be
very mindful of their mindset when
you're heading out
to a big crowd right because we've all
been isolated for a minute now
so what would you tell parents a few
advice here monica
make your shopping experience fun and
special for the kids
that's number one number two monica is
you say masked up
wash up and back up yes doesn't prevent
you from shopping
up so we've created a safe clean
shopping environment
allowing shoppers to shop dine and be
entertained with ease
and gallery sunset is here for your
shopping needs you can find
everything you need for back to school
in addition to shopping we also have fun
things to do to pass the time
we've got pacman zone indoor bungee jump
we've got fun and target
and for your back to school here needs
we've got color
cut and color lounge and jc penney hair
salon
and of course we have to get our kids
vaccinated
so we have southern nevada health
district is also offering free
cove vaccinations yes yes and also
back to school vaccination and last but
not least
keep calm parents i have to tell myself
this
keep calm the kids are going back to
school
let's get them back to the classroom
safely and with confidence
all right very cool andrea i am out of
time but that was some really
good stuff and where was all this fun
stuff when i was a kid i'm
upset about that right now no this is
good i'm so glad you guys are providing
all this because our kiddos need it
they've been through a lot
and it's time for them to decompress so
thank you so much hey good luck with all
the back to school shopping stuff you've
done a great job over there
all right folks okay thank you
absolutely hey and don't forget to catch
my mlj show facebook
live weeknights at 7 p.m of course i'm
going to replay this
sherry i had no idea she was going to
say that but i can tell you as a parent
you know this even though your kiddo
is a young man now it is so expensive
first of all the backpacks because they
want the coolest stuff they've seen on
tv
of course and then you got to fill it up
with all the school supplies
and you know the school supplies are
going to be like different this year
because they are you know because of
covid
so that was really exciting it's going
to save parents some money you bet and i
love what she said all right so she said
mask up
clean up back up right and vax up
that's right all right there's a lot of
ups just remember them
and get them all out there to shop let
me tell you you got to get up to get
down we want to get through this school
year oh yeah first you got to get up
all right okay we got that we got that
part